we are joined on the line by senator ted
cruz of course senator
from texas he's host of verdict
available anywhere you get podcasts
as well senator cruz good to talk to you
again sir ben
always good to be with you so let's talk
about your new proposal
to prevent democrats from packing the
court so democrats refuse
studiously to avoid saying they will
pack the court which suggests that they
obviously want to pack the court uh
you're proposing a constitutional
amendment that would essentially set the
number of justices
at nine on the supreme court what are
your hopes for getting something like
that through in a time when the senate
can't even decide whether or not to pass
like a simple budget proposal
well i don't think it has a high
prospect of being passed i think the
nancy pelosi house would never pass it
uh but i do think it has a reasonable
prospect of being voted on and getting
every senate democrat on record
right right now they're playing a game
where all of them i believe
intend to pack the court if they win
but they don't want to admit that
because that's a very unpopular position
with the american people it's why joe
biden and kamala harris
are are doing such gymnastics to avoid
answering the question
and so i'm hopeful that that between now
and election day
that that that senate leadership will
tee this up for a vote and get
every senate democrat on record so the
fact that the democrats continue to
flirt with packing the court is a pretty
astonishing thing i mean they've already
politicized the court
in their court picks and in their
refusal to even listen to the ideas of
originalists
but the idea of packing the court really
does fundamentally break the system
combine that with the fact that they are
talking about getting rid
of the filibuster and adding states to
the senate what you're talking about
right now
is bringing a grinding halt to the
institutional trust
of the united states which is already
incredibly fragile at this point
i i think that's right and the
democratic party today is being driven
by the extreme left it's being driven by
uh elizabeth warren and bernie sanders
and aoc
if we wake up and and the government is
run by biden schumer and pelosi
it's it's katy bar the door i mean that
they will
there is nothing too extreme or radical
i think you're right that they'll add
two states to the union because they
think that'll give them four
new democratic senators i think they'll
do that at the outset i think it's a
hundred percent
that they will end the filibuster and
when it comes to packing the court you
know it's interesting i think a lot of
people right now still dismiss
that threat these democrats are deadly
serious if they weren't it would be an
easy thing for joe biden to say no to
but he's not going to say no because
they intend to do it
and i'll tell you one of the the biggest
tells that they intend to pack the court
is the talking point went out about two
weeks ago that every democrat follows
and i gotta say
i admire the message discipline of
democrats when they put a talking point
out
everyone down to the dog catcher and
dubuque
on the democratic side says word for
word the same thing
their latest talking point is is
orwellian in nature it is to redefine
what it means to pack the courts so
their talking point
is well republicans have been packing
the court for the last four years
well no packing the court does not mean
filling vacancies that's something
presidents of both parties do that's one
of the things that happens
packing the court does not mean
confirming or not confirming nominees
that's what the senate
does under the constitution packing the
court means one thing very specific
it is adding justices to the u.s supreme
court
to put your cronies on there and to try
to take it over
fdr tried to do that he tried to expand
the court
from nine justices to 15 justices he
tried that 1937
and even though he had massive
democratic majorities in both houses
his own party told him no because it
would destroy the independence of the
judiciary
and it would politicize the court what
fdr
tried and failed to do that's what joe
biden intends to do
i believe if they win so talking about
you know
where things stand in the in the actual
race obviously the senate races
everybody seems to be ignoring them on
behalf of the presidential races which i
think is a huge mistake i mean the
presidential race is going to go how the
presidential race goes everybody's
focused in on it i think everybody's
mind is basically made up
but the margins of these senate races
are extraordinarily close from iowa to
north carolina
from maine to michigan i mean there are
a lot of very close senate races
putting aside the killing of the
filibuster which as you say will happen
what do you think is the first move
democrats will make
uh in terms of policy if they were to
win the senate as well as the presidency
look the the the last hope we have for
the republic if
if god forbid joe biden's elected
president
is to hold on to a slim majority in in
in the senate
because that's the only institution
capable of standing up to the radical
left if chuck schumer
is the majority leader as a functional
matter
aoc will be majority leader i'll tell
you why because
schumer will be terrified of being
primaried from the left in new york
state
he's seen democrat after democrat beaten
with a primary from the left
i i believe there is nothing that aoc
demands that schumer would say no to
because he wants to protect his left
flank so i think they will end the
filibuster immediately i i think
packing the court i think uh
expanding the number of states i think
granting amnesty to every illegal alien
in
in the united states and trying to make
them voters as quickly as possible
and you know when it comes to packing
the court
so that would mean in the first six
months of next year
we would be seeing probably four new
supreme court justices
they would all be hard leftists and what
does that mean
well as you know ben i have a brand new
book called one vote away how a single
supreme court seat can change history
uh that book answers that very question
what is it that's
at stake for you at home and and the
book it became the number one best
seller on amazon
nationally the book each chapter goes
through the fundamental rights that are
hanging in the balance free speech
religious liberty
the second amendment all of our basic
rights that we're right now
one vote away and if the democrats take
power and they put four leftist justices
your and my free speech rights will be
taken away our religious liberty rights
will be taken away
our second amendment rights will be
taken away and i wrote this book
to come out right now right before the
election for people to read and
understand
if i want to have these freedoms going
forward
the presidential election matters and
the senate elections
matter enormously so
speaking of your book one vote away how
a single supreme court seat can change
history
uh senator cruz i'm sure you've been
following this supreme court decision
there's a four-four split
on whether to rule on a pennsylvania
decision the the pennsylvania supreme
court which is
appointed and partisan fashion is
actually elected it's not even appointed
ruled four to three along democrat
republican lines that essentially
they should be allowed to count votes up
to three days after the election and
that postmarks
are not required so you could
theoretically vote after the date of the
election and have your vote
counted in the state of pennsylvania
john roberts sided with the court's
liberals
you use your book is titled one vote
away but it seems like for conservatives
success success on the supreme court
level is always one vote away
it's very irritating uh it's hard to
think of how many five four
decisions have come down on behalf of
liberal causes by republican appointees
this seems like another one where it's
tied four four and now
as andy mccarthy at national reviews
pointed out if justice
if amy coney bear becomes justice amy
coney barrett and this
election issue comes down to
pennsylvania and votes being counted
after the election
you're going to have the specter of the
supreme court split 6'3 with republican
appointees but 5'4
if you include roberts with the liberals
ruling on the issue of which ballots can
be counted which
i can't think of a situation more
calibrated to destroy confidence in the
supreme court
well that that is exactly right and and
and it's something that
uh i i think the pennsylvania supreme
court
as with democratic governors across the
country they're all trying to set up a
scenario that that invites voter fraud
that invites people
to vote in pennsylvania after election
day after you see the result
to cast fraudulent votes and and
i think that's profoundly dangerous the
the issue with john roberts is
is is an enormous challenge the last
chapter of my book
goes through a history of supreme court
nominees going back
to dwight d eisenhower and i discussed
john roberts at
great length i've known john 25 years
he's a friend of mine but but
but it is sad to see what has happened
to john roberts on the court john
roberts has become
the new sandra day o'connor and i think
he despises
donald trump i think i think it is
personal i think it is visceral
it is difficult to think of two human
beings more antithetical
than john roberts and donald trump and i
think that's profoundly dangerous
there's another chapter of my book that
talks about bush versus gore
and and democracy and the last time we
had a contested election
was 20 years ago i was part of the legal
team
representing george w bush in in in that
matter i was a young lawyer working
working on the campaign
actually heidi and i met on the campaign
we were in cubicles about 20 feet apart
from each other and and if you remember
what happened
the last time we faced this on election
day george w bush won
but in florida the margin was very close
and so al gore sent in an army of
lawyers to file lawsuits all over the
state
challenging the outcome and and i went
to florida i was in tallahassee
for the entirety of the recount it was
utter chaos
we had um in the war room we had a white
board with a chart
of seven different lawsuits all of which
were pending simultaneously
any one of which could cost the
presidents the united states
the case went twice to the u.s supreme
court
the first time we won unanimously nine
to nothing the supreme court
said what the florida supreme court
which was a partisan democratic court
what it had done was wrong it sent it
back
the second time we went to the supreme
court on the question of remedy the
outcome the court split
five to four and and the court concluded
5'4
that enough was enough the votes had
been counted four
separate times george w bush had won all
four times and under the law
you couldn't keep counting and counting
and counting and counting and the
election was over
36 days we had chaos and uncertainty in
the united states and the world
didn't know who our next president was
going to be
this time around we could see it
markedly worse instead of just one state
florida we could see litigation in two
three four five states
simultaneously it's one of the most
critical reasons
we need a ninth justice so the court
doesn't split
4-4 so that there is a full court that
is able to resolve
whatever election disputes come up now
senator ted cruz his book is one vote
away
how a single supreme court seat can
change history so senator cruz final
question for you obviously
final presidential debate coming up on
thursday the moderators have decided
that now
they'll be able to mute the mics during
those two-minute segments where where
people speak
uh trump obviously trailing in the
national polling what should
trump's strategy be in the debate uh
coming up on thursday night considering
that as always he will be fighting not
only the demographic but but also
presumably the moderator
well i'll tell you who i wish there was
a m mute button on the mic
as the moderator the moderators have
been a train wreck in every one of these
debates
they are partisan leftists it is idiotic
republicans going forward we shouldn't
allow this to happen
i have suggested we need to totally
revamp debates
in presidential primaries the republican
primaries
primary debates ought to be moderated by
people who actually will vote in the
republican primary we have primary
debates
moderated by a bunch of lefties who want
every republican to lose
and then general election debates let's
stop playing this game
where partisan lefty democrats moderate
debates and try to torpedo
uh the republican let's instead instead
of hiding and pretending the bias
doesn't exist
let's acknowledge it and own it and
have as moderators one open conservative
and one open liberal and so for example
i would love to see a presidential
debate moderated by say
you ben shapiro and say rachel maddow
and just not hide it you're a
conservative she's a liberal
you're going to ask tough questions that
democrats have never heard a moderator
ask and mata will ask frankly the same
questions any other
reporter would ask but it at least makes
the bias open and transparent
that's what we ought to do for this
election you asked me what trump should
do
focus on issues and substance don't
interrupt and yell and scream
don't make it a personality show don't
the democrats want this to be a
personality context
this needs to be a battle of ideas if
it's a contest
between free enterprise and socialism we
win if it's a contest
between the rule of law and the
constitution and the bill of rights
versus anarchy and riots in the street
we win
but trump's going to have to make it
that because the moderator and joe biden
don't want it to be focused on ideas
on the supreme court trump the first
question of the last debate is is why
did you nominate judge barrett
unfortunately president trump said well
because i can and i won
the answer that i hope he gives next
time
is because we need a justice to preserve
your free speech rights
because we need a justice to preserve
your religious liberty because we need a
justice to preserve your second
amendment
and joe biden wants to appoint justices
who will take away those rights we need
to focus
on the terrain of the battlefield of
ideas
that's how we win senator ted cruz his
new book is one vote away how a single
supreme court seat can change history
senator cruz good to talk to you good to
talk to you by the way ben you didn't
respond would you enjoy moderating a
debate with rachel maddow
oh that'd be a party man i mean first of
all it'd be so much fun it'd be so much
better than
what we've been watching which is just
terrible in every way i'm very much
looking forward to
kristen walker ignoring anything good
about trump it'll be it'll be very
exciting
it would be spectacular and you could do
another debate with you know
mark levin and chris cuomo um you could
do honestly
this would be so much more watchable
though the ratings would be so much
better it would be
it would just be it would be much more
watchable i totally agree with you i
totally agree with you full objectivity
is is the death of journalism so
senator cruz good to talk to you take
care thanks
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content